[Musique]
il déclaré décédé je sors un nouveau
führer chercher de capitaine à bas les
travailleurs voulaient pas l'impression
d'être un peu facho sur les bords de
loire mais facho ça fait chier les gens
pour ça
et qu'est ce que tu penses de l'amour
tollé au rail a claqué bon évidemment
j'ai apporté vous manqué d'amour dans
mais peut-être je pars en encore de
pierres non je suis pas amoureux de vous
mais je trouve sympa parce que j'ai à
présent vous êtes promet quoi
complètement venons mais pas pour mais
au fond c'est nulle part me
ils sont 50 100 200 peut-être sur la
côte d'azur
plusieurs milliers à londres c'est là
qu'est née il ya dix ans le mouvement
punk à londres je suis à la recherche de
patrick à niçois de 21 ans réfugié en
angleterre depuis quatre ans on m'avait
dit que je le trouverai facilement à
piccadilly circus
ce jour là aucun peuple au pied de la
fontaine mais en revanche un bonus
j'apprends vite que par définition le
puck est avant tout un instable ou
plutôt un craintifs
a nice on m'avait beaucoup parlé de
leicester square
le montmartre londonien et je me rends
compte en effet que des artistes qui
n'aime pas vraiment les peintres trop
jeune et souvent trop excentrique avec
leurs tatouages pas très tolérant
un coup de téléphone de nice et
j'apprends que patrick sera aujourd'hui
deux côtés de king's road
voici king's road c'est un peu la rue
jean médecin à nice commerces en tous
genres beaucoup de punk en effet mon
information était bonne je questionne au
hasard mais personne ne connaissent pas
que le roi d'époque
patrick le niçois pour moi puis on me
dit d'aller plus haut près d'un square
où des peuples sont actuellement
rassemblées sur le chemin
j'assiste à un véritable ballet de
coiffure in
paf
comme ce photographe je suis piégé par
d'époque qui exige une livre tous francs
pour se laisser filmer ma balade ne sert
à rien pas de rassemblement puck à
l'horizon je continue mon chemin sûr je
crois tu as la chance
pourquoi ne sert-elle pas au rendez vous
à l'arrivée ce pour la première fois je
rencontre les français qui connaissent
patrick niçois perpignan pas pignon est
ce parce qu'il connaît bien non bah oui
j'ai ce côté je sais pas on peut trouver
aujourd'hui s'est jamais aussi q
finalement film indique quand même deux
endroits où je peux trouver ce pack 10
ans vole d'abord quartier où les
squatteurs font souvent leur nid ni
grillage et malheureusement pour moi
de toute évidence la propriété privée
reste un droit sacré en angleterre
le même soir je retourne à pic à 10
toujours personne
un peu plus tard gelé en bulles avec
laurent un copain de philippe dans le
quartier populaire de camden où beaucoup
de preuves squat nous questionnons de
jeunes loubards qui de toute évidence se
fiche de nous le plus frappant à
plusieurs portes mais sans succès drôle
de découverte en revanche lorsque nous
revenons la voiture
c'est qu'a pu lui faire sa bonhomie
passer les petits jeunes auteurs jacky
flambé pour la filmer ouais tu qui ont
raconté des conneries
[Musique]
deux levées
grâce à la musique je fini par retrouver
patrick le niçois
la nuit était fausse tout comme la mode
et la violence points derrière des
accoutrements vestimentaire un peu
débile et des coiffures fantaisiste une
révolte pourtant authentique est juste
celle d'un gosse qui ne demande qu'à
grandir dans la paix et la tolérance
j'ai l'impression que la première
qualité pour un peu et c'est d'être
insaisissable donc parce que bon déjà je
n'ai pas de travail tout ça donc je peux
le bouger quand je si je peux déménager
je déménage alors quoi bon si six
quartiers j'en ai ras-le-bol à bages
fait ailleurs comme on a pris pas loyer
n'a rien du tout on pouvoir une maison
n'importe quoi donc
mais rien qui nous rattache nulle part
tu n'es pas un travail tu peux même pas
si je connais pas je vais travailler de
manif
j'ai pas envie quoi j'ai l'impression de
perdre mon temps je travaille j'ai
l'impression de rater des trucs c'est
bon je vois mal an ferme et a travaillé
genre toute la journée pour m'amuser le
week-end j'ai l'impression si je suis
enfermé toute la semaine j'ai
l'impression de rater plein de trucs
moi ce que moi ce que je veux faire
disons branche on sait rien amusé quoi
c'est tout il ya plein de mecs qui font
ça s'amuser ou oubliées biais quoi
pendant leur immobilier le monde qui
t'entoure parce qu'apparemment il plaît
pas ce monde dans lequel tu vis j'espère
qu'il me plaît pas c'est que vous vous
ce que je m'en fout quoi j'ai
l'impression qu'avant tout la façon de
s'habiller ou la coiffure c'est une
forme de provocation déjà
voici une provocation enfin moi j'aime
bien et quand les gens il aimait les
emmerder les gens présents mer qu'on y
voit habillée comme ça et provoquer ça
veut dire regardez moi j'existe savoir
que j'existe mois déjà je suis pas jo le
commun des mortels je n'ai pas vraiment
dire que j'ai calé tout et n'importe
quoi mais bon j'aime bien que quand je
vois dans la rue que les gens il voit
une différence entre moi et eux
je m'associe pas tout je vous investit
très bas dans la rue patrick dans 10 ans
ou 20 ans il sera comment ça on verra
bien ensemble tu t'imagines marier avec
louisa ball en génoise non non je ne
suis pas du tout sûr belles villas sur
la côte d'azur
n'importe quoi t'imagines à jour que tu
puisses te retrouver en taule oui enfin
quatre murs moi je suis papa longtemps
le seul petit passage et comment tu as
vécu sa malle
[Musique]